c'est une clinique mobile et ce matin
elle part de moscou en direction de la
campagne et des datchas premier arrêt le
petit village de pierre niess à la
mission convaincre le maximum de
résidents de se faire vacciner contre la
coved 19%
ces femmes sont passées tout droit parce
qu'elles ont comme tant d'autres déjà eu
la copie
loubat elle monte les marches mais à
reculons pas lui c'est son fils qui l'a
convaincu mais elle se méfie du vaccin
russe mais à mon âge advienne que pourra
dit loubat qui finit par tendre le bras
quelques autres l'ont suivi mais cinq
heures plus tard seulement sept
personnes ont été vaccinées
c'est rien c'est décevant et c'est un
désaveu du vaccin russe dit la docteure
les nacoulma cour carrée péri entre
nicolas et n'en veut pas non plus même
s'il n'a qu'à descendre la rue pour le
recevoir ce matin il vendre son système
immunitaire de plan les attaques dos au
mur pas étonnant qu'avec ce genre
d'attitude la russie affiche un des taux
les plus bas de vaccination de tous les
pays développés à peine 10% à moscou les
cliniques de vaccination sont vides
aussi à doha alina nous dit qu'elle
attend d'avoir accès un vaccin étrange
et à nelson est vrai qu on a fait
ndp échos
donc là qu'est notre île et naïve en
kiev et sa mère sont d'ailleurs les
premières et les seules passante
vacciner que nous avons croisé au
centre-ville en un après midi
c'est un échec monumental un aveu rares
du maire de la capitale sergueï
sobianine qui est exaspérée
mais le message ne passe pas et les
conséquences sont catastrophiques
cet analyste scientifique sauf que les
autorités officiellement en rapporte
trois fois moins
il dit que les russes n'ont pas l'heure
juste et vivent dans un monde parallèle
et désinvolte depuis des mois sans
contenu
résultat des rassemblements complètement
irresponsable comme celui ci au centre
commercial dette ce qui mirent qui a
écopé d'une amende et d'une semaine de
fermeture obligatoire mais ailleurs la
fête continue vacciner ou pas les gens
se rassemblent à leur guise pippo rogers
dont des livres ou des commentaires
à ce rythme c'est la transmission du
virus de la comédie neuf qui va
contribuer à l'immunité collective et
pas la vaccination dit le scientifique
sont morts
la russie misait sur ses vaccins mais
c'est raté l'idée de le rendre
obligatoire a été rejetée aujourd'hui
par le président vladimir poutine qui
affirme avoir été vacciné mais avait
refusé de le faire publiquement
ici tu as marre alter escaut
radio-canada moscou